[Music]
holy crap people
holy crap a man tom holland boy genius
is soy wonder that's the best way to
describe this guy he just put out
something on instagram i mean by the
time we're uploading this would have
been yesterday when he did this but he
put out something on his instagram story
you know when he puts out something like
this he's got he's got to be in
coordination with people at sony marvel
publicist when he puts something out
like this and this easily could be the
biggest tease he's ever given about toby
maguire specifically tobey maguire being
in spider-man no way home wow
you know what's funny about this
all i'm really feeling about how it's
been going down with wanting to know
about toby and andrew being in here is
so many of us believe it already and all
i feel like it is lately is us just
slowly crawling towards that
confirmation line all it's been like is
just confirmed
i can see
toby and andrew or ate it just just tell
us to make it a hundred percent for sure
damn you tom holland he was on his
instagram and he put this on a store
here's what it is look what that is
people look look what that crap is
you put out there
me
can i get a ticket
for what movie me at the window it's
freaking toby mcguire
and it's spider-man outfit that's
spider-man
movie and if he the tom holland man
if he's the one who's gonna be going out
there putting a photo of toby maguire
specifically to get a ticket for
spider-man no way home this is the
biggest confirmation of them all and it
feels like every week has been this is
the biggest confirmation out of what
he's presented this is the biggest one
he's done
well yeah i mean it's a concealed face
toby mcguire it's even it's it's even
like a visual metaphor for what's
actually happening because yeah at this
point it just feels like everyone
literally everyone involved from sony to
these trailers and tv spots they're
putting out and tom holland even andrew
garfield like everybody seems like
they're really relishing in almost the
meme of poking and prodding and watching
us go it's the biggest confirmation yet
like i have a feeling that they out of
any cycle of online coverage or geek
speculation they have to be paying more
attention to this than even normal
because you know they see all this stuff
but this feels like a very calculated
set of teases that are absolutely
designed to just keep spider-man away
home trending on twitter every minute of
every day yeah and it's very effective
because it's always trending yeah
they're just poking the bear at this
point it's their way of doing that
teaser that we've wanted of just knowing
like or show them in the trailer show
them in the trailer this is their
version of doing it this movie has
already had so much online marketing
without them doing any of it and here
you go here's your teaser toby mcguire
and it's not even a photo from
spider-man no way hope how brilliant
would it be if this was from spider-man
no i hope
that's where peter gets sucked in from
right before he never fights bones
he never loses uncle ben in that
universe actually would fit the mcu that
much more how insane would that be and
to top it off more i mean we we actually
came across this a couple days ago and i
wanted to share with you guys because i
haven't seen too many people actually
talking about it there was this very
interesting leak that we saw on
yahoo.com we don't ever really talk
about articles that we discover on yahoo
of all places basically there was this
twitter user have his account pulled up
right here his name is hey he follows me
oh look at the friends i'll follow you
right now dominic yeah dominick leakes
get those scoops man
come on man and give us the inside track
dominick kravitz it was good i didn't
know he followed me he's basically
signed up with uh the subscription
service called barkbox and they launched
a no way home theme box it's like items
for your dog
or your [ __ ] no 500 items or your
doctors quote verbatim what yahoo said
needless to say this type of promotion
requires companies to license materials
for promotion on their packaging that
means marvel and sony's own promotional
efforts are responsible for this new
leak so what is this new leak well let
me show you the video here it is
spider-man the way home the bark logo
and this really cool image of spider-man
in the newspaper and i was and i saved
this because this is a really cool image
but when i looked a bit
and i looked up here
i saw that toby is in the corner and i
was like whoa what the [ __ ]
so um
yeah there is the image it's uh not fake
i did not fake this so
there you go
i hope that's proof enough that this is
real
if if anyone has any questions or
needs any more confirmation i can try
and do the best i can and uh trying to
prove that this is real this is what i
got in my bark box so
i think they may have messed up guys
honestly when i first saw this video i
don't know exactly what the hell he was
talking about so he posted some hd
photos on here and then if you take a
look at this this was the crazy part and
remember this has to be like approved
before you put something out like this
so if you look at this is the main photo
right here of what he was showing a
video of it's really in the webbing
right there in the freaking corner
of the frame the corner of the frame
that is not tom holland's spider-man
break it down john look at the eye shape
look at the fact that it's a solid edge
around his eye and so i mean toby
maguire's got pretty big spiderman eyes
and then the webbing i feel like is the
most telltale because you got those
protruding very tangible-looking web
designs that come almost to points when
they dissect you know they shine that
way it's got to be toby
it's got to be tony mcguire's one
thing's for sure that's not tom
holland's spiderman not one of the suits
looks like that not even one of the new
suits that have been presented for the
movie that he's going to be wearing
that's not him that is clearly toby's
and this is what we mean by these little
marketing teases like that's an easy
thing to miss
like we saw the video we didn't even
catch it at first yeah you know
so
yeah guys this is the journey the slow
crawl
to a confirmation grasping at a million
threat and that's the other brilliant
part is there's so many little threads
that you could easily look like a
conspiracy theorist if it none of it
came yeah exactly it's been brilliant
marketing and i'm all here for it and i
hope that they can keep this going and
not confirm it 100 until we're in the
theaters and we see it unfold i'd be a
okay with that 100 satisfied but guys
what do you think about tom hall and
posting this leave your thoughts down
below once you go ahead subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button last but not least
adelia chamberlain you are going to be
coming out here this saturday to los
angeles to attend a little event called
the showdown spectacular now
i don't want to go to it
i don't care about it i even told
christian harloff that from schmoe's no
fake thing it's been growing whatever
and i sold christian to hell with you i
don't give a damn about this showdown
anymore they can all die every one of
them he can die every competitor can die
my faction could die it didn't matter to
me to hell and then i found out you're
gonna be attending and immediately went
all right i'm gonna do a little bit more
extra work so i can have those few hours
off on saturday to go to the spectacular
give everyone at the show down the
middle finger and just to say hi to you
because you have been with us for so
long and you've been so gracious
so kind the most beautiful soul
what more could you ask for
screw them love you i'm only going there
for you and if anyone approaches me
being like oh greg left your past
matches i'm gonna be like yeah okay
you're not a delia so get in the chamber
line oh if you want to talk to me yeah
but you know what that line's closed off
only you
only there's only one spot it's
reservations maximum occupancy one no no
emittance without prior rsvp
to hang out with greggy
screw you christian harlan
[Music]